hey guys scoff just kidding we're having
fun look at this one-way aggression
that's the key to a delightful
conversation hi guys welcome to this
video my name is grace Helbig if you do
not have a subscription to this channel
you should get one by clicking subscribe
because I think I've proven myself
worthy of that already usually my Monday
videos are associated with my podcast
not too deep but right now we're on a
small hiatus which means that you should
go back and re-watch and re-listen to
all of the episodes of not too deep you
know that you eat food and then you
can't breathe right that's a sign of
good health right now while we're on the
haters I thought I would experiment with
an old friend that's right I'm gonna
comment on your comments
I haven't commented on your comments in
a very long time so let's dive right in
we're gonna start with Twitter yeah
Sophia person to person to person from
the dome know when a new person comments
on one of my social media platforms I
grace the crap out of them and welcome
them to the it's grace family I used to
hate people then I praise people now I'm
going to grace people because it's all I
have left
also side note the person that I'm
reading the comment of is almost never a
new person to comment on my social media
so you can leave that comment in your
brain yeah Sophia more like yeah so fuzz
I love spitting you've been grace I was
inspired by grace Helbig to preorder
Grayson style and then transform my desk
bass it took seven hours that doesn't
seem like that should have taken seven
hours do you have no hands doesn't
matter that looks great good job you did
that tangible actual results I'm proud
of you but I'm most proud of sofas
they're always there for the most
sensitive
part of you your but are you there for
my butt
yeah Sophia don't answer that you I am
melt two to nine for a new person to
person to person
AM L two to nine for more like what's
that Sam for arms muscles low
self-esteem cool I appreciate your
honesty you look great
oh hey grace helbig I found you in Cosmo
magazine ah I heard rumors that this was
happening the rumors are true MERS guys
if you have the ability to go out and
get yourself a Cosmo magazine there's
lots of maybe tips there's also a lot of
tips for instance mine daily dressing
affirmations it's a little segment from
my book grace and style and it's in the
magazine this month that's really
awesome
go get yourself a copy if you can and if
you can't suck a thousand dick subscribe
senorita why did I roll my are
unintentionally saying Yura Ariza
they're much more America new person to
person immersing signora any some more
like signora Ariza with his phone decode
that Sudoku yoga course pro tip never
listen to grace helbig's not too deep
whilst doing your nails or you'll end up
murdering your fingernails oh because
you're shaking from laughing I hope not
because you're on the path to becoming a
serial killer and you're starting with
your own fingers you know they say don't
mix cough medicine and alcohol don't mix
making a murderer in homeland that will
you
oh now let's go to Lisa ramp BRE knew
there's a new person in person BRE more
like BRB psych I'm gone forever leaving
you with a gaping hole that you love to
get over through years of self torment
and regression hours of therapy
II and lots of money taking out your
pain by shopping on the Internet you've
been great
hi I cry actual tears because you're not
coming to Ohio for your book signings
feel bad for me yet no okay well please
come to Ohio like you can come to my
house I'll give you fries Q much and if
I said yes I'm not going to I'm sorry
I'd be very honest with you did I just
miss lis dude now I feel really sheshe
sorry I just I'm sorry I'm not going to
Ohio oh hi though evil yeah new person
first members and evalue n-- more like
eve member that sarah she had dog paws
tattooed on her boobs and I was all like
new boob graze KTM ca-16 oMG it's a
youtuber with a book you are excellent
at saying what things are but I'm
reading between the lines a little bit
and I'm detecting a little pessimism and
sarcasm about another youtuber with a
book to which I say why not are you
upset that youtubers are making books
why why not why are you upset because
it's too many opportunities given to
hard-working people then what are you
upset about are you upset about
something in yourself it's okay just
think about those dog print tattoos that
you've got you don't have those do you I
hope you said no if you did it just got
weirder than a reality that I'm by
myself
rod meets world new person in first
never God meets world more like world is
what a coma kunuk just kidding but maybe
it is because this always in chaos and
everyone's hoping from pieces you can
grace I want this book but our guys
gonna get some style tips oh that's a
great question rod and a lot of people
have asked if there's gonna be
information in my style guide for men
here's the deal yes there will be tips
for everyone but also it's not just a
book about fashion tips it's
kind of a creative hodgepodge of
different things related to the fashion
and beauty world for instance there's a
new excerpt available on Wattpad and it
is a diary entry written by a pair of
sweatpants and that's a running story
throughout the book so if you want
please please please go to my profile
Wattpad comm slash grace Helbig and go
read the excerpt that is available for
you guys before the book comes out and
there's already an excerpt on there
about my dad taking me shopping when I
was younger so the book not only has
tips it has personal stories and then
it's got some other creative writing
parts that I think you might enjoy one
of those things if not all or many of
them or none we can't all be a DOS new
album can we water under the bridge
haha we're fine now it's going to be
which way we have ever heard of it
galaxy defender new person and person
number and galaxy defender more like
galaxies what I call my body wouldn't
let me finish it because then your was
going to say cook your wood grace I have
a uni exam in an hour and I'm watching
this will probably be more useful than
trying to learn anything now I know I'm
screwed one of the greatest things that
you can ever learn is self-awareness so
it sounds like you've passed the test of
life with flying colors explain that to
your professor and if they don't listen
to you just tell them that you're a
galaxy defender tie your cape a little
tighter and jump out the window
don't Tania MD Barnes me first memorize
the Tanya M what's the n stand for makes
me want to walk away for no specific
reason other than I'm just sort of
PMSing and you didn't really do anything
to offend me direct
I'm just really sensitive youmu grace
that screaming doe also grace you want
to be a beauty lifestyle vlogger and you
can't hide it anymore
Tanya M I wrote a book called grace and
style the art of pretending you have it
cats out of the bag and the bag is a
cute modern cross body clutch that
doesn't make any sense
grace Keller knew person-to-person
immersion grace Kevin more like Grace
Kelly or Helen Keller
are you a combo of the two are you a
beautiful mute when is the show coming
to Broadway
you've been graced how does she not feel
claustrophobic in there this was
commented on the video in which I redid
this workspace and a lot of you thought
that I was claustrophobic there is space
between here and here also I would ask
how does Obama do it some of the most
successful people have their desks
facing directions like this I've heard
once from someone that read it online
one time maybe Pinterest well the
different commentary or comments this
week guys I really enjoyed doing this
and I hope you enjoyed it let me know in
the comments if this is something you
liked and I should continue to do this
every week because I'm thinking about it
I'm also thinking about fried rice don't
forget to go to walk pad and read
another excerpt from my book and go to
grace now book come to pre-order or to
find out more about the tour that I'll
be doing in February and we're coming in
how you could come see me if you want to
I don't know
that's wrap anything else you need to
know because I'm a genius